It's pretty nifty and you know what these little black dots are?
You wanna know what these little black dots are?
*laughs*
yup
Epic Street Fighter bag
*heavenly singing*
and cut
Sorry for the audio quality. We're just using the on board mic.
Ted's here from Aputure.
Sup. How's it goin?
The reason why Ted is here with the Aputure halo right now.
Is, if you look at a bunch of the footage
You can see that under everyone's eyes, it's pretty shadow and pretty dark
until we actually start lighting them and stuff
Well, we have to light them
With another light, also by Aputure
It's another light, and that can be a pain in the butt
When you're kinda just running and going and you just need to see someone's eyes
So we put the halo on the lens, or right above it. Whichever one
We get a nice eye light. We can fill in those shadows so we can always see everyone's face and eyes
That's the idea.
So Nick and Carmichael are about to fight for this awesome Street Fighter Academy bag.
I wanna see a fight to the death. Who ever lives... They get the bag!
We have rules that kinda disqualify some certain hits.
Hands don't count. Face of the blade does not count. Edge, only counts.
That's how we do it!
I tend to go a bit more defense and counter attack.
I like to get in there, cut him up, and just walk away.
Come on, Obie.
It's really hard to concentrate, Obie. You're too cute.
Super small and pocketable internal LED
Battery chargeable by USB
4-6 hours
Spencer got it up and running, working great.
But at the wide lens that I'm using. We got a little problem.
The lights in the shot.
So what we're going to do, we're actually going to take it off the lens.
Dim that down. I got controls right here.
Alright, I'm rolling.
But now, it's dark.
That's a huge difference right there
That right there is a huge difference
Be ready to put your defeated honor and pride inside that bag.
Take it to the gym.
Can't wait to fill that bag full of condoms and go visit your mom.
Sudden Death!
*agonizing scream*
That was a challenging battle, but he really gave it all he could with that last round.
Respect, dude. "Respect"
A lot of you out there that shoot videos and photos, you know what this is, Israeli Arm.
Right there. So, hold that for a second.
So, what the big issue with this is you mount this on the camera
and someone just comes by and goes "oh let me see that"
and they just twist it. "and this is tightened" and it's all tight and locked
and they're just breaking that thread
You're not even putting that much effort.
ARRGH, why do you do that?
I just spent 150 dollars on that.
This guy
*constapated noises*
I can't do it
I thought you were strong.
Not that strong.
But look, I can do it.
You do the Aputure one.
You little cheat.
An anti-idiot Israeli Arm for 40 bucks
So if you make a video on YouTube talking about products
People are going to accuse you for making an advertisement
In this case we didn't get payed to say any of this stuff, we're just fans of Aputure's equipment.
It's affordable, and it's useful, we use the lights, those point lights especially, nearly everyday.
And there's no better testament than that.
A lot of you who watch the channels are filmmakers yourselves and we figured
We should pass on a good word.
There's something that's affordable, and works great.
Those single source lights have my full endorsement.
I love them <3.
Alright, thanks.
That fact that you took that, I totally got your thigh.
Yeah yeah, that was my thigh...
Subscribe for more vlogs and behind the scenes